encore un plan social qui tombe en plein
été cette fois ce sont 30 suppressions
de postes à l'imprimerie même rattachée
au groupe Serge Laski le site compte
actuellement 198 salariés dont quatre
apprentis une première petite vague
qu'ils ont essayé de neuf la première
fois mais réussi à sauver quelques-uns
la aire propose 30 l'année prochaine ce
sera encore une nouvelle vague ils
veulent revenir sur l'accord des 35
heures sur les contrats de travail ils
veulent faire de la polyvalence dans les
sites enfin c'est tout un global qui
essaie de prendre en compte sur le dos
du salarié Jean-Noël Laski fils du
propriétaire du groupe et directeur du
site n'a pas voulu s'exprimer devant nos
caméras son directeur financier qui est
aussi aux ressources humaines réfutent
quant à lui toutes les propositions des
syndicats quelques membres du comité
d'entreprise
ont évoqué des formations qualifiantes
de longue durée le problème c'est que
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à des
baisses activités qui sont importantes
et nous devons gérer l'urgence et donc
on peut pas conserver des collaborateurs
en dehors de l'entreprise tout en les
payant la mesure que nous proposons sont
des mesures douces je parle pas des des
éventuels licenciements secs auxquels on
devrait
peut-être arriver mais ces mesures
d'erreurs de réorganisation en interne
qui nous permettent véritablement de
diminuer la volumétrie du plan sont des
mesures douces qui remettent pas en
cause des habitudes fondamentales mais
qui sont pour nous très importants parce
qu'ils nous permettent de gagner en
productivité et donc de donner d'offrir
à nos clients des prix meilleurs retour
à l'extérieur du site avec les salariés
des salariés qui regrettent que de
l'argent public servent infini à de la
classe sociale encore plus rachète les
locaux pour de façon à faire une école
d'art graphique en fin de compte des
fonds ont déjà été versés afin de
préserver les emplois et en fin de
compte au lieu d'un pseud la plante
sauvegarde d'emploi ça se termine par un
plan de suppression d'emploi la semaine
prochaine l'activité reprendra
l'imprimerie tourange elle-même enfin
pour les quelques employés qui ne seront
pas en vacances le prochain comité
d'entreprise extraordinaire devrait se
tenir à la miaou